Many popular films
today feature animals
or otherworldly creatures
as a main character.
Behind these lifelike
performances
is a real human actor
bringing an authenticity
to these creatures
that CGI can't replicate.
These actors bring a specific
physicality to a character
and on set, give
a real performance
that other actors can
react to in real time.
That performance then
becomes the framework
that postproduction builds
a fuller character around.
These performances are captured
using a green-screen suit,
a motion-capture suit,
or a blend of the two,
with practical makeup
and costumes.
Here are seven films that
use creature performers
in creative ways to
elevate the story.
Creature performer Terry
Notary wore a mo-cap suit
to capture his physicality
as Buck the dog
in "The Call of the Wild."
Having Notary on set giving
a committed performance
was said to help
elevate the performances
of the actors he
shared a screen with.
As a creature actor, Notary
was more that just a stand-in.
He often conferred with the
director and other actors,
working through shots
and scenes with them.
To train for the role,
Notary filmed the
movements of his own dogs
and watched the
footage in slow motion
to understand how they walk.
Actor Harrison Ford
praised Notary's work,
saying it was important
to have someone
to participate emotionally
with on screen.
For Disney's live-action
"Dumbo" remake,
the beloved baby elephant
was made completely in CGI.
But to get believable character
movements and emotion,
creature performer Edd Osmond
wore a specialized green suit
to capture
authentic movements
and interactions
with fellow actors.
Osmond spent hours observing
how elephants walk
And for certain shots,
a stunt performer stepped in.
Osmond spent hours observing
how elephants walk
and trained himself
to look believable
while hunched over
on all fours in stilts.
Osmond also had to consider that
this was a baby elephant,
so movements had to
be a bit less confident
and more sporadic.
To play the character, Osmond
wore multiple different suits.
First, a performance suit
that looks like the character
for actors to interact with.
Then there was the bare-bones
"ant-man" costume
used when Dumbo was
running or walking around.
Since Osmond's head
was pointing down,
a camera was mounted
on the top of his head
so he could see
where he was going.
In some instances,
a more well-known actor
will do their own
creature performances.
"Fleabag" star Phoebe
Waller-Bridge
did her on set performance
as L3-37, wearing
a modified robot suit
that was part practical
and part green screen suit.
As a uniquely funny performer,
it needed to be
Waller-Bridge on set
alongside Donald Glover,
who played Lando,
to capture the right chemistry
between the two characters.
Her L3-37 performance was
modified in postproduction
to look more like a robot,
but kept the same physicality
Waller-Bridge
performed on set.
Dozens of
creature performers,
including Andy Serkis
and Terry Notary,
wore modified mo-cap suits
when performing as apes
in the "Planet of
the Apes" trilogy.
Finding a way to deliver
believable ape performances
led production
to Weta studios.
Using new
technology at the time,
2011's "Rise of the
Planet of the Apes"
became the first production
to do motion capture
in a live-action setting.
Then in 2014's "Dawn of the
Planet of the Apes",
they set up over
50 motion-capture cameras
throughout the sets,
all sending the footage
over WiFi to remote servers
so there was no wires to hide.
Then in "War of the
Planet of the Apes" they pushed
even further by shooting
motion capture in the snow.
but creature performers
walking on crutches
instead of hands and having
different gaits than real apes
meant entire paths
and foot print patterns
had to be
digitally recreated.
Speaking of actor chemistry,
Dan Stevens,
who played the Beast in the
Disney live-action remake
of "Beauty and the Beast,"
wore a Beast mo-cap suit to
act alongside Emma Watson.
It included stilts to
be the proper height
and weighed over 40 pounds.
Stevens noted that the suit
was particularly difficult
to act in during
the waltzing scene
and said he feels lucky
he didn't lose his balance
and fall onto Watson.
Not all creature
performers are used as
only a framework for CGI.
In the instance of "Scary
Stories to Tell in the Dark,"
creature performers
Javier Botet, Troy James,
and Mark Steger all
wore practical costumes
that incorporated their specific
body types and movements
to bring the iconic
monsters to life.
The unique physicality
of character actors
was used for the movement
of the on-screen
monsters they played.
The costumes were created
with painstaking detail
by Spectral Motion
specifically to be on camera.
Botet's costume
even incorporated
a slight green-suit element
for his character's big
toe to be removed in post.
Another instance where
the character actor's
performance was
almost all practical
is from Doug Jones in
"The Shape of Water."
Jones, who's worked with
director Guillermo del Toro
on several films, including
as Faun in "Pan's Labyrinth,"
played the Amphibian Man
in a practical costume
with elements of digital
retouching added later,
like blinking
and micro gestures.
Even the gills were practical,
mechanically
operated by puppeteers.
The glowing bioluminescent
aspects of the suit
were also practical,
using UV paint.
Del Toro decided to have
the amphibian
character be practical
because it was the
main character
and the story's
emotional center.
Therefore, Jones
had to perform
to give it the
character's soul.
What are some of
your favorite movies
with creature performers?
Let us know down
in the comments.